[Musique]
l'actualité de cette semaine marquée par
le premier rendez vous de campagne
présidentielle d'emmanuel macro un
déplacement à poissy pour une rencontre
avec 250 habitants devant un public à
qui il a notamment évoqué suppression de
la redevance audiovisuelle ou encore la
création d'un chèque alimentaire face à
une prochaine envolée des prix en marge
de ce déplacement lundi se tenait aussi
dans les yvelines le départ de la
deuxième étape du paris nice après une
première journée à mantes-la-ville la
course cycliste s'est élancé d'auffargis
direction orléans depuis plus de dix ans
le département et partenaire de la
société à etsaut organisatrice de
l'événement mardi 8 mars journée
internationale des droits des femmes et
dans le département l'occasion
d'inaugurer à versailles un nouvel
accueil de jour dédié aux femmes
victimes de violence c'est la onzième
structure de ce type dans les yvelines
alors que la guerre perdure en ukraine
après les offensives russe la solidarité
s'organise à voisins le bretonneux une
famille accueille déjà des premiers
réfugiés femmes et enfants la france
envisage l'arrivée de cent mille
personnes depuis l'ukraine la guerre en
ukraine au coeur du sommet européen
versailles qui s'est tenue en fin de
semaine prévue de longue date cette
rencontre finalement bousculé par le
conflit a été l'occasion d'aborder les
questions de défense de l'union encore
de sa dépendance énergétique et pour
terminer cette semaine une note plus
légère avec le retour du festival
électro chic dans l'agglomération de
versailles grand parc concerts et
rencontres avec le monde de l'électro
pendant plus d'une semaine après deux
années d'organisation compliquée avec la
crise de l'aco vide
[Musique]